hello reject nation I'm Greg Alva I'm
John Humphrey yes you are and we're a
good son
because we're the really are if it's 824
doing it you know it's going to be a
positive fulfilled time they only do
positive driven pieces but they also
usually do pretty good pieces yes
they've got they're always positive and
uplifting young so you can always count
on Saturday on patreon to totally
jumbled TJ cuz you're a jumble full of
good time and a lot of people only even
have a lot of people that told me to
watch this set of watch it with you
because it's a 24 really yeah I know
that I like day 24 yeah well you've
mentioned it like several times here I
do like a 24 we're did bad about really
why do people no I'm just surprised
people think that anything about those
about my brother yeah I told you about
the program he's forced to attend
announced it shouldn't be there
don't convert seconds before they do
understand that no nothing happens oh no
exactly what the rest is being held
right designers
once we get killed in there so kinda
walked in again get another 10 grand to
build it up where are you how much my
can you get right now oh whoa oh my gosh
you two think I'm doing this what how
they look like
what are you gonna do
[Music]
oh man what a tense situation Finn don't
be confused yeah a place where there can
be a lot of fun if you lay on my trip
you're gonna have a good time good time
what did I say John all movies find
YouTube most movies and have positive
words in the title everyone usually
quite sad films to sit through yeah that
song does look intense yes look intense
man that was the first time in a while
were like I forgot it was called good
time when the title popped up I was like
ah the irony yeah I mean it's a cool
plot happy it's intense when you have
like a friend or someone you know in
jail I can only imagine your own brother
and you like you can bail them out but
you don't have $10,000 I think she got a
bail bondsman you get a bail bondsman
they reduced the price at the tree
granny could have gone 3 grand really
fast how maybe he was onto the bail
bonds and he was like need 10 more grand
for the crime brother Chris yeah what is
that decided you say the point Robert
Pattinson and to quote the quote in
trailer yeah he looks like he sets a
screen on fire I don't know if that's an
accurate representation to me quoting
the clothing all I can see is that meme
of the Wayne Gretzky quote with Michael
Scott written next to Robert Pattinson
looks like he does a really cool job and
I like Robert Pattinson which is I'm not
a big fan of those Twilight films
splotch is what we all tend to associate
him with he's on planning a work outside
of Twilight where he really does shine I
feel Pattinson as this sort of made it a
point to work his behind I'll have to be
like never check it out I'm a good actor
beyond toilet everything he's done
especially late
has been like something immersive yeah
in a character right now and just and
the style of direction here does around
me like you said Nightcrawler I got a
little bit of a Nicholas when the ref in
the Bible did with a model with sent you
know with a more gritty approach to it
yeah I feel like Nightcrawler and like
Nicholas Winton Rothman filmed it don't
really go handheld they have these like
really composed shots and I feel like
that the combination of that with some
raw gritty cinematography and some
flashy hypnotic type of imagery as well
putting you into this you know time
crunch experience I like movies I really
have a very defined ticking time clock
yeah yeah like where the tension always
building and all guys oh my god I would
die in jail he really looks like he's
going to die this almost takes those
circumstances and makes them look like a
sci-fi like the thing is like you see
the feeling I get is very like well the
choice of music in the style of
Direction really does for gonna happen
yeah that makes you feel like you're
almost watching like a minority or boy
yeah I have but it is like this intense
it's just so intense but it is this sort
of realized situation hypnotic and
abrasive in in all the a 2410 yeah very
very much a twenty four trailers we tend
to use words like hypnotic yeah well
before we wrap this up totally jumbled
my friend TJ the more time goes on the
closer you are to having that baby be
born dude you will be father you know
why we gave you the shout on this video
because when you were making that baby
you were having a good time my way
heaven who loved you TJ love you Teebs
remember during the Google hangout and
this all this time to relate what's your
real name he finally decided to tell us
his real name and the audio code is a
lot is a is like a damn movie
we never find out we'll never find out
like season 15 subscribe to the real
rejects quick that notification bell -
on Twitter and Instagram and shout out
to Robert Pattinson I hope there will be
a time where when I see a trailer of you
I won't go he's doing a lot better since
Twilight
take care